Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, this week on
Gotham was the beginning of Arkham Asylum’s
season long story and it’s going to serve
as the battleground for a war between the
powers that be.
I know everyone that’s played the Arkham
games will have a lot more fun with this,
but Arkham in general is probably the second
coolest place to visit in Gotham next to The
Batcave.
Which as we learned in Dark Knight, is technically
not located inside Gotham County.
Stupid Know-It All Two Face.
I’ve also got some big big comic book Avengers
and Batman vs Superman related news that I’ll
mention at the end of the video.
But careful for spoilers if you haven’t
seen the episode yet.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, Here are my
Top 5 Moments…
Number 5 - The Penguin Stops By
This explained a lot of the questions I had
after the last episode.
With the whole Gordon Barbara Murder Mystery
plot.
Penguin used a fake name, so they’re just
going to keep him a secret until it blows
up in their face.
Which it will.
There is no dirty secret in the Batman Verse
that won’t eventually blow up in your face.
Based on the way the action played out, their
partnership right now seems like it’s more
about the Penguin using Gordon to get rid
of his trash rather than Gordon taking advantage
of someone on the inside.
In the comics, Gordon has worked with the
more sociable villains like The Penguin and
The Riddler.
A lot of Batman villains lack the desire or
the intelligence for actual detective work.
I was surprised that Gordon split with Barbara
over the secret.
Their marriage in the comics was always on
the brink of divorce because of things like
this, we just get to see more of it because
this is a 22 episode season instead of a 2
hour movie.
That’s right, gotham just got picked up
for a full season.
Originally I think it was only 14 episodes,
now the total is 22.
Which makes the chances of a season 2 much
much better.
Number 4 - Fish Mooney Explains the Sexual
Politics of Gotham
I kept trying to find comic book easter eggs
in the singer characters she was auditioning.
But all I could find was a villain on Batman
Beyond named Spellbound.
Making them fight to the death did remind
me of Heath Ledger in Dark Knight.
Two candidates, but only one opening.
I don’t know why they needed to linger on
the seduction moment so long.
I guess they were just trying to make it extra
sexy but I thought it was kind of awkward.
It seems like Mooney will use the woman against
Falcone.
Because she got rid of his last girlfriend.
Number 3 - No Country for Old Batman Villains
It think we can assume the Penguin is the
one who hired Gladwell.
We already know he was the one to trash the
restaurant.
That was what the bit with the Cannoli was
at the end.
He was getting rid of the hitmen he hired
to kill everyone.
Gladwell wasn’t someone from the comics,
even though he did take one of the victims
to Arkham.
Now that they’ve got an extra 8 episodes
this season they’ll probably re-write everything
they haven’t shot to extend that storyline
to the finale.
Meaning we’ll see the characters playing
around Arkham More and More.
The evidence that the Penguin killed the Waynes
or was directly responsible for it is stacking
up.
Based on what Bruce said, their murder had
something to do with the Arkham City development.
And who have we seen staring at a plotted
map of the city with Arkham at the center.
It’s like the penguin created the war for
Arkham as a way to clear a path for himself.
So you have all the most powerful crime bosses
fighting each other and when the dust settles,
the Penguin will assert himself.
Number 2 - Bruce Wayne, World’s Greatest
Detective In Training
I wouldn’t be surprised if he does end up
connecting his parent’s murder to arkham
and the war that’s going on.
Gordon would be the one to handle the dirty
work.
But solving the mystery would be a big way
to keep the Bruce character involved in the
story in an important way.
Otherwise there’s no reason for him to even
be on the show every week.
It’s still early in the season, but David
Mazouz is a main character, so Bruce Wayne
will have to become a critical part of the
solution.
And because he’s a tiny-sized batman right
now, the best way for him to help is via detective
work.
Batman has riddle solving abilities that rival
edward nygma.
Which actually reminds me, he’ll probably
figure everything out to and just land on
the wrong side of the war.
Like he’ll wind up on the wrong side of
Gordon.
Or Bullock will push him too far.
Number 1 - The Rise of Arkham
So they’re going to rebuild Arkham Asylum
and turn everything else around it into a
dump pretty much.
The original plan was to gentrify it and make
everything nice and shiny.
Like the way people refer to Ronald Reagan’s
Shining City on the Hill Speech.
Arkham was going to be this shining example
of hope at the heart of the city.
But now obviously it’s headed in the opposite
direction.
It’s turning into the Arkham we know and
love.
The Harvard for psychopaths.
The origin story they’re trying to tell
here will explain how all these batman supervillains
like the Joker, Hugo Strange and the Scarecrow
could come from Arkham.
What happened there that it produces so many
crazy villains.
We’re just starting to see that happen.
Psycho Ward being built next to a giant trash
dump.
I can’t wait to see what a gothic nightmare
they’ll turn it into.
Let me know though, what was your favorite
moment, and do you think the Penguin really
killed the waynes.
I know it’s different from the comics, but
even if he didn’t do it himself, he could
have hired someone to do it for him.
Overall I gave the episode a B. I’m loving
the Arkham storyline but I feel like the story
is still getting bogged down trying to service
the Gordon Barbara plot and the other minor
villains.
What I’d like to see is them just drill
down more on the core characters.
The Penguin, Maroni and the Roman, Bullock
and Gordon.
I don’t mind the amount of time they spend
with Bruce either.
But I feel like they need to make him a more
substantial part of the action.
Like he needs to be more precocious.
Like spending more time snooping through the
police archives and causing trouble.
I feel like Selena Kyle would be of great
assistance in such matters.
Right now if feels like the show is trying
to be so serious with villains poking eyeballs
out, that it’s not letting the characters
have any fun.
Let me know what you guys think.
Do you like Gotham dark and gritty or do you
want to see some more humor.
It doesn’t have to be campy humor, but I
feel like it’s a little too serious right
now.
Someone needs to blow off some steam.
Next week is episode 5, Victor Zasz shows
up again.
I’ll post my video after the episode airs.
So be sure to subscribe to get it.
The big news right now is that Robert Downey
Jr was just written into Captain America 3
and a producer on Batman vs Superman explained
Wonder Woman’s origin story.
I’ll be doing a separate reaction video
next for this, but Robert Downey Jr is getting
paid 40 Million dollars to appear in Captain
America 3.
Which all but confirms they’re doing the
Civil War storyline.
Again, I’ll post a full video explaining
everything, because there was literally a
behind the scenes war with the marvel executives
over the movie.
It’s crazy.
The Wonder Woman news is just that her origin
story will be the New 52 version from the
comics.
That means that instead of being made of clay,
she’ll be the daughter of Hippolyta, queen
of the amazons and Zeus.
In the comics, she takes the title of God
of War.
So that’s what she’ll be in the movie.
The demigod daughter of Zeus.
Which will explain her powers.
Right now click here for that Robert Downey
Jr Video.
I’ll post it in a couple hours and click
here for last week’s Gotham Video.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and I’ll see you tonight.